دعم حلف الناتو لاوكرانيا ثابت ولن يتغير
هذا هو تعهد وزراء خارجيه دول الحلف في
اليوم الاول من اجتماعهم في بوخارست
الوزراء
الكثيف الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا والمساعده
في اصلاح بنيتها التحتيه للطاقه وسطا موجه
من الهجمات الروسيه
ضد المدنيين في اوكرانيا واكدوا انهم لم
يعترفوا ابدا بضم روسيا للاراضي
الاوكرانيه
الذي حمل فعليا لغه تتحدث رغم هواء جريس
روسيا
[موسيقى]
عندما يتعلق الامر بمنطقه البحر الاسود
فهذه منطقه ذات اهميه استراتيجيه حيويه
بالنسبه لنا ولحلف شمال الاطلسي حولت
روسيا اجزاء من البحر الاسود الى منطقه
حرب لقد راينا صواريخ قادمه من السفن
الحربيه الى المدن والبلدات الاوكرانيه
وسنقوم بتعزيز وجود الناتو من البحر
الاسود الى بحر البطيخ
كان تصريح الامين العام لحلفي بعد ان ضغط
على الجرح الروسي الذي فجر الحرب واكد ان
اوكرانيا ستنضم الى الحلف يوما
شكرا شكرا يجب تهيئه الظروف لسلام دائم
يضمن ان تكون اوكرانيا دوله مستقله ذات
سيده يجب علينا الاستمرار في تقديم الدعم
العسكري لها لذا فان رسالتنا من بخاريسته
انناتو سوف يستمر في الوقوف مع اوكرانيا
لاطول الفتره ممكنه ولن نتراجع عن ذلك